[Music]
[Applause]
thank
you that's nice of you is it time to
protect our home with a giant Dome well
over the weekend Donald Trump slammed
neocons in the corrupt establishment for
wasting blood and treasure in Foreign
Wars true even my camouflage Speedos are
on back order because of
Ukraine so he floated the idea of a dome
Over America to protect us from our
enemies and you know those domes they're
starting to work and you know those
domes are starting to work I didn't like
it when Ronald Reagan suggested it
because we didn't have the technology we
do have the technology now and we're
going to build a giant Dome over our
country to protect us from a hostile
source and I think it's a great thing
and it's going to all be made in the
United States and that's something that
I consider
productive he right the only Star Wars
that are getting worse are in the
movies but I can see it now from the
creator of my pillow and my slippers my
Dome
made in
America with that over your head and a
my pillow under it you'll really be able
to
relaxium it's not even a word and when
Trump watches our guys operate those
things it's unbelievable missile coming
in missile coming in when I watch uh our
guys operate those things it's
unbelievable missile coming in missile
coming in these Geniuses sit down most
of them are you know they're from MIT
but they sit down bing bing
binging it's gone it's amazing I think
we could use do you like that I mean
isn't that better than giving other
countries billions of dollars billions
we're going to give billions of dollars
to other countries and so they can build
a dome but we don't have a dome
ourselves we're going to have the
greatest Dome ever it's a good point
yeah it's about time we close the Dome
Gap we're sitting here completely
exposed meanwhile Canada's been covered
in Saran wrap for years years but one
question remains how can we get Mexico
to pay for
it oh also how will it look well there's
only one covering that's guaranteed to
keep our country safe and
[Laughter]
secure
beautiful Tyler what do you think this
Dome over the country would look like
can you describe it for us in my voice
or Donald Trump's voice Donald Donald I
I would with Donald
Trump uh well frankly Mexico will pay
for it and we're because it'll be the
shape of an avocado we say it'll be no
think of it think of it think of it and
it'll be also be the shape of Adam
schiff's giant head have you seen his
big head yes it's like an Iron Dome
because there's nothing in it right and
then the pencil the pencil neck there no
it'll be so great he'll have to he has
to up the Annie on the wall right yes
first it's the wall now it's the Dome M
the wall will go up and the Dome will
cover it yes and then the Dome will have
a wall so the aliens can't get in
frankly
yes it'll be like a bread box you know
wall and the thing could slide open and
closed and it gets covered with jam and
nobody cleans it Emily you know it's
true I mean uh we did help pay for the
uh Iron Dome in Israel why shouldn't we
start building our own listen I would
sleep way better at night knowing that
we had a missile protection system
because I don't know why people think
it's farfetched that soon missiles are
going to start launching at us the you
know trajectory that the world is going
in you know World War I coming soon
woohoo but the first thought that came
to my mind was Trump really took
securing the Border very seriously
because like you said first he's stared
with the walls and that's not enough he
wants a four dimensional little whole
country secured going on but truth to be
told it's doing miracles for Israel so
what if now they start shooting the
rockets at us why should we be so
helpless and unprotected and then B I
really do think aliens are coming and
that's why they're distracting us with
another Hunter Biden crisis and coming
for Elon Musk and you know I just think
it would be a great idea so I'm with you
Trump for once let's let's do this 4 d
border I'm with you well how about you
know LST would you feel safer in your
cardboard box on the street if you knew
that you actually did have a roof over
your head for once it's true it's
thousands of miles in the air and you
can't see it it's my own little Dome
it's my little
cardboard it keeps it makes me feel
secure like a cat uh listen all I know
is this uh Trump said we needed a wall
we didn't get a wall now we got like 10
million people living here that don't
belong so we needed a wall I I think I
want the Dome if Iran's going to start
lobbing nukes uh I totally want the Dome
put me down put me down for two walls I
want the wall with Mexico I want a wall
between us and
California let
those
and then I want a dome and yeah you
could just you only need the Dome you
could do the Trump Dome where it just it
just starts at Arizona California and
then activates and it's like the com
over Dome it's the Dome over you the
Dome
over
yeah you know it's interesting if you
think about it cat what if mus decided
to just build like a like mini domes
right and so if the if the government
the they don't want it like it's like
some places can have a dome other places
don't like if San Francisco doesn't want
a dome fine move to San Francisco don't
have a dome but let's say you know uh
mil pedus California likes a
dome yes yeah I don't know it's not it's
not surprising to see Trump doing I mean
he was like a real estate guy right yes
yes he's just misses it probably a
little like first it was the wall and
now the Dome I don't know how I feel
about the Dome specifically but I do
like the idea of our you know National
Defense being about defense right and
not about nation building which has been
for so long now where as he did mention
you know so many people dying so much
wasted money wasted lives fighting other
countries Wars a defense perspective
that would that's a long time coming for
me I agree I think that like this is
where you should put the money because
we always talk about we need to fight
these wars because they're going to come
here but what if they can't come here
what if we just Dome red States and then
call it survival of the fittest yeah
they and also if they don't like it um
oh excuse me I live here yeah we can
move to Florida be better we all follow
Hannity to Florida well the blue States
they can get a dome abortion if they
want get rid of it get rid of it we can
just hit them like a popomatic yeah you
know just press down on the Dome and
watch their little buildings tumble
around I want a personal Dome I'm sick
of people just cover me I think I think
smaller domes small do
SES my shut up now all right coming up
he broke a rule skinny dipping and a
stores hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else